my battery's about to die so let's play
the game of how much content can I shoot
before it dies but hey guys it is 1/2
hour Wednesday here on its Christ or oh
for sure I've never done a not yet tired
of going if I do
I went on my tumblr and asked you guys
what did you want to see reviewed today
you gave me so many options so we're in
the review a bunch of stuff so many of
you wanted me to review the How I Met
Your Mother
Susan finale let me guess you found out
how he met the mother and then Neil
Patrick Harris this real-life twins came
out and we're just adorable and then
you're like oh my god agent playing a
straight man what an amazing actor
though we championed his alternative
lifestyle with his husband and his
beautiful adopted twins and then you oh
yeah Jason Segel's in this sequel I wish
it was Seagal is that how it ended so
many of you wanted me to review the
prank you played on me on tumblr for
April Fool's Day and I don't know it was
so much of a prank as you guys just took
a very unflattering still-frame image of
my face that to be specific and post it
everywhere so I don't know if it was a
prank as much as some sweet sweet
grassroots marketing for the integrates
channel either way I laughed out loud
silently to myself I saw all of it and I
thought it was just one person's blog
going nuts on tumblr and then I realized
oh you just all chose the same icon and
it's all different blogs and Oh what is
this Oh spice I'm a very small spice
rack what else did you guys want to see
reviewed um my but it exists I do have a
but my mom is a wonderful woman she
broke her wrist a little while ago by
falling off of the bed putting pajamas
she's so fabulous so sweet she's gonna
be so upset that I told you guys that
but she's strong she's stronger now
horses sometimes I do feel like a horse
like when a horse is fall you're just
like oh they don't just trip they fall
and that's how I am like I just go down
and then it's like everyone's like oh no
that's gonna take a lot for that
creature to recover and then usually
just have to shoot it the Juno Awards
unfamiliar but I assume that it's an
award show thrown by you in your
basement bedroom is masturbating to a
photo of Ellen Page she's cool
cool face Hana's impression of you I
think that hannah has a wonderful
impression of me I think we like each
other very much
RuPaul's Drag Race I haven't watched it
yet this season so everyone just shut
them I one of those things in the end of
my tongue is like a blister and it hurts
and instead of ignoring and I just keep
fighting it and like isn't that just so
symbolic of life and like how I
constantly try to sabotage ourselves and
destroy our own happiness
okay what else